yes hit that drunken kung fu
so sick
hi my name is Jared Hughes I'm swerve I
am a stuntman and actor I've been in
films such as Ant-Man and the WASP Dune
love death and robots Hebrew and Call of
Duty you may know me as Thorne I am
another stunt man I'm also a
videographer and producer and director
that does Action specific oriented
things I work with a lot of big
YouTubers like Eric Kinsey people that I
put in extreme situations and make them
do crazy [ __ ] hey guys what is up my
name is Omar Zaki I am a stunt man and
parkour athlete here in Los Angeles I've
stunned doubles actors like Lil Dicky on
the TV show Dave I'm actually getting
hit by a car next week if you watched
ultimate tag I was the geek on Ultimate
tag I've been killed by Chris Pratt I've
done commercials for Nike and whatnot
done a lot of really really great fun
things and today I'm going to be
watching and reacting to some stunts
here on BuzzFeed John Wick chapter three
don't see any other way
so this stunt man got the hardest wreck
uh award they had blue screen on on
every platform it's real it's like
completely that dude is taking all this
ants you know these are real Falls
they're real hits maybe a little padding
but you're still falling you know 30
feet hitting
oh
you can tell it's visual effects after
he hits that railing you can see kind of
like accelerates very very unnaturally
very quickly to hit that next panel and
in that moment it just stands out as you
can see that there's been some visual
effects tampering with it which sucks
because it probably did that and made it
real and the stunt performer took a mad
beating that day Atomic blonde so
Charlie's trained with 8711 one of the
top action uh martial arts teams in the
world they put her through a lot of
workouts and training the choreo in this
is absolutely sick because it's like
also utilizing like the rope and so
utilizing props is what separates a lot
of uh different styles the biggest thing
about these are the stuntmen that don't
really get as much shine their reactions
are killing it right now and making all
of her impacts look really really heavy
they had to build the choreo to make it
seem that the hits were effective enough
to stun the guy so she can go from one
person to the
so that I believe is a a foam foam prop
that they built so that she could
actually make contact with some people
that guy is actually taking yes it's a
foam pot to the face but it's still got
some weight to it so that's respectable
to take that just totally dead onto the
face
also just the sound design in this
moment that's fantastic okay so so for
that the way they pull that off is you
usually create a stopping point for the
door I believe there is some contact
that's happening but you know you can
see that it's hitting the wall there at
the same time maybe it's not fully
hitting the person in the face maybe
it's kind of hitting the wall and their
face at the same time but that's a great
great moment right there
that's sick that's really sick
oh
oh that guy just went neck first into
the ground has taken the behind the
scenes when Sam Hargrave the stunt
coordinator or fight coordinator was
talking about this he told his performer
one thing he said hey no matter what
don't land on your neck and that is
exactly what happened and they used that
tape because it looks gnarly a lot of
like movies you can tell with the way
they shoot it like whether you could see
the ground or not tells you kind of like
how advanced the stunt people are
because whether they're hitting the
concrete or the in this case the tile
the hard floor versus shooting it so you
could not see the ground and there's a
mat there and stuff like that like this
choreography is brutal there's an
amazing scene explainer descender to the
people who do not know what it is under
it basically like two wire points and as
he's riding down one wire it slows him
down as he gets closer to the ground and
you're talking about like it has to be
dialed in so perfectly and so precisely
golden eye opening scene
I love how quiet this is it's very
intense
oh
God that looks real Is that real that's
terrifying
honestly I'm most impressed by the
camera operator keeping him in frame the
whole time that's impressive
Jesus all practical all real there's no
CGI ladies and gentlemen but I tell you
what like bungee jumping is more sketchy
than skydiving just statistically I
prefer skydiving way more than buddy
jumping although I've done it here we go
with Inception that right there oh that
bike wreck yeah I've done a few car hits
off of a bicycle never off a motorcycle
but for NCIS I got hit by a car
six times in one day so
I feel his pain what a dream fight scene
to be able to do this would be so so
cool to do this I'm so jealous like you
have you would have to rehearse this so
much to be able to get the gravity
transitions from wall to wall to to have
this this feeling of out of control
chaos but also in control where you can
actually execute the choreography that
you're supposed to do because they do
have choreography in this moment they do
have blocking they have to stay in frame
of the camera they have to not punch
each other in the face but it has to
look chaotic and out of control and my
gosh did they knock it out of the park
with us it's funny because like the more
like brutal the stunts are like when you
see like in Fast and Furious or
something when you see a car flipping
down the road there's somebody in that
car doing that for real that's not CG
they actually do the easier things CG
and the more complicated stuff like that
like car hits flips like a lot of the
most insane Falls and stuff like that
they're all real I mean you know you can
tell when it's a dummy falling off a
building versus a person right they're
on wires here for sure
um
it's just a rigging has to be
fine yeah to be able to create this
Mission Impossible Fallout I don't want
to lie but I heard that they rehearsed
this a lot maybe hundreds of times
because this is practical best son ever
no it's not ever but
I love this he's biased and they
actually made his oxygen rig for this
jump they made that mask and everything
custom for this movie you start to get a
hypoxia which is basically where you go
Looney I guess above like 15 000 feet
you have to have supplemental oxygen
I just love the guy the conscious guy
who has to pretend to be unconscious
since they're just flying through the
air Legend of drunken master this guy's
kicks are amazing and uh always got
really inspired by the way that he moved
his his legs
he's so sick and in all reality like
we've got some cool movies with some
cool scents here in America but there is
no stun team in the world like Jackie
Chan stunt team they are all insane yes
hit that drunken Kung Fu if you watch
how Jackie Chan sets up his fight scenes
there's no shaky cam there's no uh crazy
camera movement because he always says
that he wants everybody to fully see the
action see that they're actually doing
what they're uh what they're doing yeah
there's no cheating it I love how it's
all about the character with Jackie it's
not just about the action it's about
it's about the character we all know
that oh yeah those are real coals that
man is rolling through
yeah props like they're everything like
they just take everything to the next
level because like especially when it's
when like this is an older film and a
lot of older like Hong Kong style fights
and stuff like that more low budget or
at least access to less of the cheats
that we have here and that we had here
in the media center of the world you
know so they they did it more practical
you know and and it's insane we are
about to look at everything everywhere
all at once
nice Hong Kong fall that's a great fall
we call that a Hong Kong follower HK
twist
um where you kind of just jump in the
air and you twist a bunch of times until
you hit the ground and doing that on a
breakaway prop that's a nice nice stunt
they're killing it
so this is again uh creative use of
props that we really uh enjoyed because
and especially this movie does a lot of
that they really utilize it
um
this man is using his uh Fanning pack as
a whip chain right here is like a good
example of where
you use the creative choreography and
I'm pretty sure they use wires in this
this flip that's such an incredible shot
so sick that's an incredible fight scene
all right we're looking at Captain
America's Civil War right now all these
all these jumps in the first scenes like
almost all these look like wire jumps
very like held in position coming down
nice and clean Landing this is such a
cool scene so what they what they use
for this team there's a lot of behind
the scenes on this stuff I believe they
called The Magic Carpet where they
actually have it's either like a
treadmill or essentially a big mat a big
carpet that is being pulled by a car and
the way they film it is they just frame
the car out and then they have people
running either on this treadmill or on
this giant carpet that's being pulled
and then you just film them running so
it looks like they're running super
super speed but in reality they're just
running on a platform that's being
pulled by a car and then they have the
rest of the cars around them driving at
a slower or regular speed so that it
looks like these guys are running at a
super speed so this is a practical
effect which is super super cool
[Music]
oh my God kicking off the ceiling what
is that I don't remember that part a few
of those look bad
all of these are stunt performers uh
that all these cars that are wrecking
are sliding off or getting out of the
way or where any of the pedestrians on
the street they're all stun performers
so there's a cannon roll right here
where this SUV turns over I don't know
for sure but I'm willing to bet there is
somebody in that car doing that
practically knowing a lot of these
performers myself hearing the kind of
stories that they have seeing what
they've literally had to go through
doing a certain thing 30 50 70 90 times
however many times to get it right for a
film and the level of skill that they
need it's immense I hope that you
enjoyed this and that you learned
something about stunts again my name is
Omar Zaki on this BuzzFeed stuntman
react and I'll see you guys later
thank you